a man hit nearly killed by a car in the
Central Valley speaking out tonight Hal
Goldblatt was walking home after a day
working at his synagogue when a car ran
into him in a marked crosswalk it
happened and nearly broke every bone in
his body now Hal and his family are
calling for safer roads new at 11. Sasha
Loftus shares his story and what he
hopes will change
[Music]
you really don't remember much weeks
after how gold
car he's struggling to remember what
happened he just blurted out how was hit
by a car and it's really really bad Sean
Goldblatt his wife of 48 years has been
by Hal's side as he works hard on
healing
Hal says he was hit here in this
crosswalk near Arville and Charleston in
November while walking home from a day
of work at his synagogue Witnesses say
he flew 79 feet in the air onto a
windshield and nearly broke every bone
in his body we worked really hard to get
that crosswalk put in but it's just not
enough Sean and Hal say they've worried
about dangerous driving along this
stretch of road for years statistics
show Deadly pedestrian crashes are up 14
percent in Metro's jurisdiction so far
this year crashes involving excessive
speed have seen a 20 Spike and have
encouraged
straight through they don't stop that's
why as Hal faces a long road of pain and
Recovery I will get through this and I
will make that crosswalk better he hopes
by sharing his story he can do what he
can to keep others safe I want to save
lives that's all I want to do